hi guys this is luca rampariello from
lucanobra.com
and today i wanted to make a video which
is a little bit special
so as you can see here i am in on the
chrome
web store and i'm looking at language
learning or learning languages with
netflix which is a chrome extension
my browser of course is an italian but
let me show you
without further ado what this does to
your sessions on netflix so let's open
netflix and
i'm just going to quickly write
quicksand which is
a very cool swedish tv series that i
have been watching
so for example i'm going to click on
that and
this is episode number one now
as you can see they're speaking right
now
and you have the this is swedish here
and here i have an enjoyment so you have
a strip
of double subtitles and on your right i
even have the entire conversation in
swedish as you can see here let me just
play this
for a second
see and uh i have this uh
chrome extension here already installed
i can decide to turn it off and you i
can see the full screen and then i turn
it on
i can also remove this part so that i
can see the entire screen
apart from the subtitle strip or i can
put it back
just in case you want it and i'm gonna
show you in a second what this
can do to you and for you
but here as you can see i can also click
on settings because
currently the subtitles are in swedish
and in german and let's suppose that
for the moment for a moment that you're
a native english speaker
so i can decide to change the language
here and i can put
english for example and here you go now
you can see that you have subtitles
in swedish and in english and as you can
see now
i also have if you click on this
you have a vocab so you can see
the meaning of a specific word but
there's more to it
here as you can see i can even so
just to give you an idea you have the
subtitles in swedish and
in your target language if you're
watching a show in your target language
say you're learning turkish for example
you want to watch
a show in turkish and then you can put
it in
the native in your native language
doesn't necessarily have to be english
it could be very well be italian for me
so if i want to change it i can go here
and i can change i can put it in chinese
i can put it in filipino finish
french and whatnot so that is absolutely
great
but you can also save these words this
is a premium
feature so just in case you want to save
it you you can save it for later
and if you check my article you will see
what i mean
by saving words and reviewing words and
this might
take this entire activity to a new level
and the other thing i want to show you
is that
and as you can see here if you click on
print
it will show you the script
in two languages so you have the
bilingual script
of the entire show and that is great
because you can save it
you can print it you can put it in a pdf
you can
you can do whatever you want with this
at this point what you can do
is to watch the show you can even look
at the script you can
underline the words that you want it's
just like a podcast so you can watch
obviously the purpose of watching
netflix is to actually
watch it and listening to it but this
um this chrome extension gives you so
many other possibilities of using the
same content
so there you have it i hope you liked it
and go and watch a
netflix show right now with
learning languages with netflix have a
great day
and talk to you soon
you